SPEAKER 1: Spinnaker for Google
Cloud Platform is a solution
that lets you
install Spinnaker--
the open-source multi-cloud
application delivery platform--
in Google Cloud
Platform with a couple
of clicks to start
creating pipelines
for continuous delivery
of your applications.
When you open the management
environment, which
runs in Cloud Shell, you can
follow a set of guided steps
to install a
production-ready Spinnaker
instance in a new Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster
in minutes using Google's
recommended settings.
You can change many of the
installation parameters
if desired, including installing
Spinnaker in an existing GKE
cluster.
Spinnaker for Google
Cloud Platform
also integrates your
Spinnaker installation
with other Google
Cloud Services,
such as Cloud Build, Container
Registry, and Stackdriver.
Once the installation
process is complete,
you can access the Spinnaker
UI via port forwarding
or automatically configure
a secured endpoint
using Cloud Identity-Aware Proxy
with a valid SSL certificate.
The management environment
provides many helpers
to simplify ongoing
administration
of your Spinnaker instances.
The configuration
of each instance
is automatically and
securely backed up
for auditing and fast recovery.
Helpers are provided to connect
Spinnaker to new GKE clusters
and to create accounts to
deploy to Google Compute
Engine, and Google App Engine,
and other GCP projects.
You will also have
access to the hal
and spin command line
tools, giving you
full control of your
Spinnaker instances if needed.
The solution lets you add sample
pipelines and applications
to Spinnaker that
demonstrate best
practices for deployments to
Kubernetes, VMs, and more.
DevOps teams can use
these as starting points
to provide golden path
deployment pipelines tailored
to their company's requirements.
The Hello World web
application, for example,
demonstrates a
continuous delivery setup
that builds the application
with Cloud Build,
and deploys it first
to staging, and then
to production with Spinnaker.
Once the staging
deployment is completed,
a manual judgment determines
whether to continue
with the deployment
to production.
Spinnaker for Google
Cloud Platform
is pre-integrated with Google
Pub/Sub for notifications
and can also be linked to Slack,
email, and other notification
channels.
The deployment to production
demonstrates a number
of good practices, such
as automated rollback
when the validation tests fail
and the hot standby period
after successful validation
in case something unexpected
happens.
We can see the
Kubernetes resources
Spinnaker is managing
in the Spinnaker UI
and can go straight
to our deployed app
to check things out.
You can try out
the solution today.
Just search for Spinnaker
for Google Cloud Platform
on cloud.google.com